it is a part of America that PT Barnum
would have taken great interest in
Barnum was America's most famous
promoter and in recent years his life
has been getting a fresh look two years
ago there was a movie starring Hugh
Jackman this year a book called Barnum
an American life
so we met the author and traveled the
Barnum's historic museum to explore how
Barnum defined his age and ours
the Traveling Circus that PT Barnum
created is dead but his mark on American
culture lives on he's never gone out of
the public mind Robert Wilson wrote the
book
Barnum an American life published this
summer we met Wilson at the Barnum
museum in Bridgeport Connecticut where
Barnum once served as mayor I think that
people whether they know a lot about
Barnum were a little about Barnum they
understand that he has this iconic
status in American history Phineas
Taylor Barnum was born in 1810 during a
period when the country was just
establishing its place in the world the
19th century is the story of ordinary
people spreading their wings and Barnum
help people come out he was somebody who
was really pushing them to know the
world better Barnum's first big step
onto the stage was perhaps his most
indefensible he bought the right to
exhibit a woman named Joice Heth who
claims she was a hundred and sixty-one
years old and the former nursemaid of
President George Washington he started
out as a person who had conventional
attitudes towards race for many
Americans in the 1830s he started out as
a person who put on display what he said
wasn't a hundred and sixty-one year old
slave yeah exactly in 1842 Barnum opened
the American Museum on Broadway in
Manhattan the museum exhibited
scientific instruments modern appliances
wax works and exotic animals there were
also Barnum's human discoveries Isaac
Sprague the living skeleton the so
called mammoth lady listed at 576 pounds
and the Fiji mermaid advertised as the
remains of a beautiful sea maiden
actually a monkey's body sewn onto a
fish Wilson says Barnum's career can be
summed up in one word humbug for him
humbug meant creating a stir about
something pumping something up to the
extent that people would want to react
to it ideally by spending 25 cents in
going into his museum and looking at
but the the second part of the
definition for him was if you're gonna
create a humbug and get people in there
you better give them more than their
money's worth
Kathleen Marr is the executive director
of the Barnum museum Barnum was obsessed
with the biggest things the greatest
shows but also the smallest the smallest
it also will wonder unto itself that
includes Barnum's most famous performer
Tom Thumb a little person who Barnum
found at age five and started exhibiting
at six
Thums staged wedding in 1863 was a
sensation that helped distract the
nation from the Civil War so this outfit
is a hundred and seventy five years old
yes that the math it goes back probably
to about 1850
it's the Napoleon costume that Tom
actually wore at his performances when
you say performances what is that what
do you mean he would sing he would dance
he would joke he actually had a cigar he
would even drink wine
six-year-old it sounds absurd but child
stars have been around for a very long
time Morin says that Barnum is much more
than just an exaggerated showman he was
a strong believer in freedom of speech
when the local newspaper wouldn't run
his opinions
Barnum published his own and spent two
months in jail after he was accused of
libel I couldn't imagine what he would
do with social media today he's
exhausting as Barnum spoke his mind he
filled his coffers he may have been the
first American to discover just how
lucrative entertainment could be Barnum
II becomes one of the first you know
millionaires in the country so he
actually has this incredible nugget ring
created that is an engraving of his I
ran a Stan mansion that he built in
Bridgeport in 1847 take your hand so you
can feel the weight of this gold chunk
and it's just an enormous ridiculous
statement of wealth and achievement in
everything like its subjects Bob
Wilson's book has been a magnet for
attention and that might be because of
another entertainer and businessman
turned politician I mean I think I
this of nothing else to thank president
Trump for everybody wants to make that
connection yeah is it right or not
I mean I think it's an interesting
connection to make I mean they're both
New York figures Barnum was heavily into
real estate it must be said that
Barnum's relationship with the truth was
quite slippery Barnum wrote a book
called the art of money getting yeah
exactly
Wilson says that Barnum should be judged
by the standards of his time and how he
changed he would go on to become an
abolitionist eventually running for the
Connecticut state legislature in part so
he could vote for the 13th amendment
which abolished slavery his homes and
museums burned five times killing scores
of animals his elephants invariably died
at an early age he eventually became a
major backer of the ASPCA after he
created the circus he doesn't create the
circus until his retirement and it's
never called a circus actually it's
always the greatest show on earth
because it is so much more than what
people think
Barnum also set aside money to build the
Bridgeport scientific society today
known as the Barnum Museum he died at
age 81 before it was finished this is
the third floor of the historic Barnum
building in recent years the museum has
been badly damaged by a tornado and two
hurricanes some are hoping the renewed
interest in Barnum leads to a 25
million-dollar rebuild and a continued
reassessment of his life is your goal in
this book to rehabilitate him I didn't
start out with a goal I mean I was just
interested in him as a character but
what I found was that I admired him why
did you come to admire him
I think it's that business of his
ability to change I think if you're
willing to sort of look deeper look for
the complications in his character see
the ways in which he changed then you
know it's possible to see him in a new
life the famous quote is there's a
sucker born every minute there was no
evidence to suggest PT Barnum ever said
that we should be known for what
well the museum says he should be known
for the line the noblest art is that of
making others happy that was his his
goal but he clearly he changed as he
aged and it's very interesting reading
this book and sort of re-exploring what
he was and what he did fascinating
thank you both so much
[Laughter]